germany is marking the 30th anniversary
of the reunification of the two germans
east and west
following the fall of the berlin wall
and the crumbling of communism
it seemed at the time like something of
a miracle but for the people of today's
germany there's been a change of
perspectives
the country has become more mixed more
diverse
which is welcomed by most but violently
rejected by some
and what does the younger generation
think about the way things are
developing
on to the point this week we ask german
reunification
is it time for the next generation
thanks very much indeed for joining us
here on to the point and my guests here
in the
studio are maitu bui who is an art
student
focusing on migration and she argues
that we
in west germany are rediscovering the
eastern german identity
and we must learn from it also with us
is melanie stein journalist and
psychologist
who says reunification shaped us now
we are shaping society and a very warm
welcome too to journalists and radio
presenter vladimir balzam
who believes that today's united germany
is more diverse than ever
and we should embrace that
thank you for being here folks thank you
for those three interesting statements
i'd like to begin with you
uh my two i called uh german
reunification in my introduction
and the fall of the berlin wall a
miracle because that's how it felt to me
i was there at the time and i was amazed
by what i saw
what does it mean for you today in the
first place it meant something for my
parents
after the reunification it meant for
them that the
contracts terminated my parents back
then were contract workers
just explain sort of about the
vietnamese background and the contract
workers in
east germany um starting in
1980 i guess because that's when my
father
first came to east germany um vietnam
and east germany back then had a
contract
um in during the socialist
union to invite
vietnamese contract workers in order to
work for them in companies and stuff
like that okay that's important because
many people i think many of our viewers
would not know that and
and your parents and that community in
eastern germany did they
celebrate german reunification was it
was it a joyous
occasion for them for them it was a
shock because
their contracts would have terminated
years later
and the ecosystem kind of fell apart
they had to start start to be on their
own
to find ways in order to survive not
only the contracts terminated but also
the living conditions kind of
changed in a way okay that's a that's a
fascinating introduction to your story
we'll continue on that
just a little bit shortly uh melanie 30
years of reunification
are you celebrating or what is there to
celebrate from your perspective
and well i think we are just i think
um the the reunification is one of the
biggest
historic achievements of of germany of
course
and i think it's not not a day you
celebrate with your family
um and it's maybe it's also because
um you know um
in in the years when when the
unification happened
or the year before and it was the people
who were fighting for democracy so the
players
from the peaceful revolution
um are not really um the subject
of this day you understand no tell me
explain for me
so well we had to we had the chance to
um
create a new con constitution and we
missed this
chance unfortunately so it was more a
symbolic
act in a way and a takeover and
often described as a hostile takeover
the west taking over
the east um yeah well
we we had there were people um creating
a new constitution they had great ideas
uh like the white work the white two
um an apartment environmental
protection things we discussed today but
um
politicians decided to not do that but
um decide
decided for the takeover and i think
that's a reason why people from the east
and west didn't meet
at eye level and this was followed by
some problems we are talking about today
or the younger
generations talk about today okay
vladimir you were a young teenager at
the time tell us about what your
perspective was
then and through to today well the 9th
of november 89 was actually more
important to me than the 3rd of october
1990.
uh the fall of the wall obviously i've
been 15 years of age and
my mother kicked him into my room and
said i know this is
there's really something historical
happening and i wanted actually the next
day really i've been living in
uh uh i'd lived in leipzig at that time
and i wanted to go to west berlin of
course the next day what i
did with most of my friends so school
was empty
it's been a friday i remember that and
this was just a great time you know
really to to see
all these places to meet people and to
see also the differences from the very
beginning actually when i went to west
berlin
i suddenly noticed that this is another
part of germany i
wasn't really prepared for it so um and
the third of october i mean you have to
remember it's just it's less than a year
later less than a year
this um the state of gdr this east
germany actually you know just
disappeared from the earth
and that's a very very short period
melanie was talking about how perhaps
people
in the east got got a raw deal you might
say from
from the west and i'm just wondering i
mean yeah
because it's been a democratic decision
there has been like
uh elections on the 18th of march in
1990 the first free
election in east germany which was there
and people decided people voted and they
voted for the conservative movement
which was strongly of course uh also
supported by
helmwood cole and his government and the
cdu from the west but still
the east german people decided
themselves now what would happen to that
country
it wasn't a takeover the world was also
because
i called um said you would have promised
a lot yeah
you promised a lot too much only after
one years later
um people lost trust in the government
so you're absolutely right it was the
decision of the people
they knew what they did it was based on
promises which were not whole that's
true
but that's nothing new in politics i'd
say
uh i'm just i'm just wondering my two
when we uh when we talk about the sort
of the three decades of german
reunification
do you do and you listen to that
discussion and it's continuing obviously
because with celebrations again
uh this year uh as usual do you sort of
look at that discussion and think
we should be moving on here we should be
moving away from that discussion
and moving towards germany's future as a
more
diverse as a more yeah as precisely that
as a more
diverse society i mean in the first
place
we have to acknowledge that germany
itself is already
diverse um we have lived experiences
that go beyond being eastern or western
german
and for example my story but also like
so many other
stories that have been unheard because
the story usually have been told from
the
west german perspective and even
east german people try to
tell more of their stories and i think
they are valid to be heard
vladimir i'm just i'd just like to come
back to your sort of optimistic
take on the process because uh you know
we all know that
this this term this horrid term was used
the aussies
to sort of almost look down
denigratingly on people from the east
i'd just like to know were you ever
never ever never you were never called
an aussie you never sort of no
people were amazed when they realized
i'm from the east actually yeah
you're really from me isn't that true
wouldn't have believed it so
they had their cliches in mind obviously
you know
um even my now wife when we had our
first two or three dates she
thought i'm from the west she's from the
east and uh
it took at least three dates
[Laughter]
for her to learn that i'm actually also
from the east you know
so you adapted very well to the system
probably yeah
well at the heart of berlin at the heart
of german reunification is potsdamer
platz
once it was one of the busiest traffic
hubs in the world and it was later wiped
from the map
but it's back so what do people there
say about
the coming together of east and west 30
years on
after reunification potsdamer plots in
the heart of berlin
became the biggest building site in
europe now it's once again a lively
bustling district
this is all that reminds people of where
the wall once stood
deutschland is i know germany is one
country i never accepted east germany
i'm glad it's gone
i knew the old east germany i was 10 at
the time and felt very positive about it
what came next was a very tough time for
us teenagers and kids
because our parents lost everything but
looking back i'd say it was nonetheless
a good thing
i think we're on the right track in my
generation at the latest
you won't be able to tell who's from the
east and who's from the west
is that really the case
my two i'm uh i'm surprised you know
that that uh
that's sort of an aspiration here to the
the people
in the east and the west shouldn't be
different the difference shouldn't be
apparent what do you say
i think we have to acknowledge the
differences not only between
western and eastern german people but
also the varieties
that that make the society diverse in a
way
that we have to learn from those
um identities that we can acknowledge
them
and feel compassion for them is that
happening
um in some parts it is because for
example my generation is speaking
up about those past and histories
which people don't know about yet and we
hope that in the future
german people in general not eastern or
western german people
will understand the history behind
existence
it's interesting it's good it's
complicated stuff melanie you uh you
founded an initiative called we are the
east
young mainly young as i understand it
east germans
who are proud to be east germans what
are they proud of
well they actually poke fun at the media
because
the media sometimes say well the the
people from the east are like this and
like this
and they put them all in one box and
this box is not very positive connotated
and so along side with the rise of
right-wing populism
there were never-minded media reports
and
we thought this is problematic because
the majority
80 percent who voted for democratic
democratic
political parties are not um shown
and so we thought okay maybe we have to
give them a platform
and so people on our platform tell about
their story
um they many of them for the first time
uh publicly um talk on public
what they or their family actually
experienced just experience
an example give me the example so
one a very common example is that many
people were from the younger generation
say
well they didn't have parents who had
that much time
because people of course they were busy
to
find new jobs two-thirds of the people
in east germany
lost their jobs and um yeah so they
they had to become major
very early and but also i think this
gives them strength so the
experience of transformation is actually
a skill
we need nowadays and this is what we
have learned how to reinvent themselves
yeah
yeah that's really important that's a
very very important point i'm actually
proud of many east germans what they
achieved actually in this 89 19 and also
in the 90s and now
they had to adapt to a totally different
system to a totally different political
system the word we use today is
resilience
yeah yeah yeah i think i mean not all of
course i mean not all i mean many many
many lost uh lost their jobs and had
like a broken biographies and so on of
course
of course you know especially when you
talk about minorities by the way
for example the vietnamese minority or
the cuban minority and so on they had
really really problems strong problems
so
but you are not most vigorously you did
a good job
yes of course like um it was a tough
time back then and it still
is it will always be a tough time even
whenever a person migrates nowadays to
germany they won't ever
identify themselves with the german
identity
um for example i have uncles who moved
to germany
even after my parents moved here and
for them they will always be strangers
that's what they
um telling themselves and that's what
they tell
us and the community so um
i think it's also part partially because
they experience the kind of um
sorry they experience that
their identity is not what being
welcomed here
and this is you're being very very
cautious yes i'm
quite cautious cautious because my
existence and my identity
is um in danger in the german society
like when i go outside and why
i grew up with new nazis in front of my
door
we're talking about i mean it did back
then in the 90s back then in the 1990s
especially it was a terrible decade in
that respect i think
and that's still there it's still there
has it changed at all
or is it still the same threat the same
level of threat
to to your well-being when i was
a child i could identify them by wearing
black or being skin hats
nowadays um this kind of phenotype
disappeared in a way
and they as they kind of um
became the same like everyone else and
so it's very hard to identify
the person who would put you in danger
mm-hmm
um one of the uh well i was
i was on your site and i was looking at
some of the statements that some of the
people were making and one of the
statements was
um that we we want people
in the east uh to be oh no we want the
east
to be seen as an opportunity and i said
to myself okay you want the east to be
seen as an opportunity what does that
mean
that it isn't seen as an opportunity
that it is perhaps seen
as something troubling why is that the
case and why is it still the case
if it's true at all yeah yeah i mean
it is the case that more people in the
eastern part
vote um for the afd and
but we have to ask for that right
alternative for germany party
20 in most areas in eastern germany yes
and but we shouldn't ask why do east
germans vote
that way but we should ask why could
the afd become that popular in this part
of germany and your answer your answer
to that question is
there are many answers one um in a
nutshell
well so one quarter of the east german
people have left mainly academics
this is one reason we didn't have the
movement of 1968
in east germany and i think the most
important thing is
we are missing a strong or this
the civil society is not as strong as in
west germany
so we really really um
need this but we also need more people
um
like in the media we need more
more east german perspectives because um
there there this fact that eastern
german people
um don't have that much much trust in
the media
and in the government and i think this
is not surprising and they had so many
so much hope and and then there were you
know
there was devaluation and job loss
and of course they lost trust and their
perspectives are not seen in the media
so we have to change these things and
and look what what can we really do
okay let's let's try and keep all of
that on board and
look to the future a little bit and if
you really want to get a feel for how
dynamic many parts of the former east
germany are becoming
then one place that you might go to is
the city that gave us vladimir
leipzig
leipzig is booming it's among the
fastest growing cities in germany
it's buzzing with young creative people
it's being called the new berlin
its economy has been buoyant
lifetick is like berlin 10 or 15 years
ago because there's so much going on
when you're young you want to make
things happen and in leipzig you can
leipzig has a very active youthful
startup scene
a lot of old buildings have been
renovated and the rents are relatively
cheap
major corporations are also well
represented porsche
bmw and dhl for example
despite the enormous effort to catch up
in the eastern states
productivity there is still 20 lower
than in the west
and household income is still 12 percent
lower
polls show that 57 percent of germans
say the advantages of reunification
outweigh the disadvantages
15 say the opposite where does the
future
lie in the east or the west
okay let's take that question where does
the future lie in the east or the west
well i don't know it's difficult to
actually answer that question because i
think it lies in both parts
um but from the east comes definitely a
very innovative
um let's say energetic kind of a
movement uh what i would see at least
for the for the younger generation
electric is a good example i think we've
seen that in the in this in this little
film are there other places that you
there are other places also there's
places like a little smaller place like
yena and uh drayson is another place
which is booming uh potsdam close to
berlin
to actually the former west berlin and
there are some like urban
urban areas uh which are really uh
like on the good on a good way actually
towards uh towards future
and of course on the other hand side you
have like rural
rural areas where it's much much more
difficult actually
where many especially young
well-educated women left the place
and what's left are just a rather elder
man with less education but this is not
true for the city so leipzig is a very
very good example and actually
as i'm i grew up there in the 80s and i
studied there in the 90s
i really saw a place which embraced
actually this this new time
and you know the fall of the wall and
everything what came afterwards so
it's a very good very good example
actually for my two from your
perspective what can we learn from the
east
we can learn from the east that
the world to tell your story is
definitely there and we have to
acknowledge that
um that we as especially because we're
talking from west germany from here
um that we have to find a way like you
said um
to find not only ways but also to
educate people
that the eastern germany is not
the dark part of germany like
forever because we have to find ways to
support them
to build infrastructure and ecosystems
in which
they can flourish and also yeah
yeah we want to shape the future that
was
your statement at the top of the show
how how
what are the tools and what are the
goals yeah well as as i said people who
experience transformation themselves or
through their parents they have a
certain skill they can use now
and um we show these people and so for
example
michelle bonmeyer is at our team he has
founded an association that
scaffolds basic income and does research
on it we have people
who create co-working spaces um in the
landscape
and and so i think this is one
um big part of the skill of
transformation
and also i think well people in east
germany they did not inherit much
right um so the country property
was given to the west um west germany
i need to explain for our audience to
just briefly the the
in what in the western part of germany
there have been huge sums of
inheritance is being passed from one
generation to the next
that hasn't been the case in eastern
germany and very many people view it as
simply and abjectly unfair yeah well
but it is also a chance because i don't
um take it over the company of my
parents
i have free choice and my parents will
also support me because
they couldn't do what they wanted in the
gdr and that's really a great
opportunity and i see
really many many great young people
doing um very um influential things
now we are having the digitalization
absolutely it can be really very
engaging
vladimir your take yeah well
if to be honest uh as i said um from
east germans i mean the whole german you
can learn from the from the east german
story
how you can adapt to new to new
conditions and to a new situation and
uh to challenges um that's what the east
germans learned and
i think they are most of them i'm still
speaking of the rather younger
generation
uh much more resilient actually to
anything would
may happen in the future and i just
wonder you know what we have these uh i
said earlier we have these sort of
annual celebrations and sometimes it's a
case a little bit of sort of going
through the motions
uh here in germany talking about you
know what was back then what was
you know that it was a very important
juncture in german history
and one of the cliches that is often
used in that context is that we
we all perhaps people in west germany
people in east germany
have walls in our heads still
do you have a wall in your house i
wouldn't say so i wouldn't say so i mean
i don't i would say for myself i don't
have any walls in my head
my parents do definitely but that's as i
said when
when we talk about east and west germany
and about reunification we have to talk
about generations this may be
another subject for another show but um
it depends very much
on how what you what you actually
experienced yourself you know how you
how your own life went
uh how your biography was changed so
that's really important always to keep
in mind we're speaking of 30 years after
which is a long time it's
more than a generation it's a paradox
because it's a long time in a short time
at the same time but it is
it is three decades yeah but this older
generation also passes on some
experiences
also some negative experiences to the
next generations
tell their story maybe their negative
story and reproduce
actually all these kind of breaks and
wounds and everything what
may have happened and overcome the
trauma yeah because it was
traumatic but they pass on this trauma
which is a problem
to the next generation so this is what
i'm slightly worried psychologists here
well um i have to disagree on some part
because
the studies show we share the same
values
but if you ask the east german person
does the person from the west share your
values then 45
will say no so um there is this
construct
of east and west i never felt like a
east german i was made in east german
i felt like a northern person or
european
and i think we really have to
stop using these constructs very
important point i'd just like to get one
more
perspective from my two just to just
tell me in a sentence what is your
vision for the future of germany
i think what we just were talking about
that acknowledging
that not seeing wars is a privilege and
understanding how to use that privilege
in order to support the
non-privileged okay to the point on
german reunification thanks very much
for joining us if you've enjoyed the
show
come back next time until then bye bye
and cheers
[Music]
[Music]
you